ich weiß nicht so recht ob das land
zieht aber wirklich gesellschaft
verloren will sie erst einmal kritisch
hinzu gegangen hätte das internet und
genauso wenig wellness resort
oder
laptop mit
und das ganze wirklich aus der
ärzteschaft auf den trubel um etwas zu
sich finden findet gar nicht statt
[Musik]
das ich bleich und bossard und in eve
und mehr barbara und diskutieren das
historische aufschlagen wird steiner zur
stadt oder land ich
wollte war gar nicht mehrere wohnsitze
jetzt würde wurde am stadtrand sind es
aber das frankfurter umland und wurdest
du
es ist glaube ich los ist wirklich
stadtrand aber so 10-18 zum grünen und
einigen
ja und wenn sie sie stoppen können
erleichtern und apropos privileg also
was ist einfacher tür statt das ist ein
wichtiger punkt oder gar insofern are wo
man wohnt wieder schon bestehende
mehrere wohnsitze
[Gelächter]
tier ist absurd also direkt selbst
einkaufen was sie alles irgendwie moment
die findet er nimmt der staat muss
extrem mitglieder ganz schnell gemerkt
dass wir stark so
profane haben am basteln anwalt und das
ganze team hat einmal in berlin klappen
können glaubt das vermächtnis so groß
gesteht sie sind und das erste messe hat
natur schon mehr extra tour vermisst es
ist hektisch viele fehlanreize und ich
sage das mit drei zur schule die ich
meinen städten die schweiz
in
zürich paris und grün grün grün grün und
so die kriegen ja du kannst auch ein
spannender hoch
trotzdem
hat sie jetzt möchte der schweiz natur
aber es ist interessant wie natürlich
wirklich eintrage
bewährungsstrafen deutschen sprache aber
für mich ist das gar nicht so
unrealistisch wie schwarz und dann auch
sehr an empfunden habe sei dank habe
lang durch natürliche chemie zur
pluralität der stadt dass ich habe mich
an der staat immer schon fasziniert dass
du einfach mit der unterschiedlichsten
weiter schädigen die unterschiedlichsten
seine hobbys mappus vor mit branchen
finanz und schon passiert unabhängig
entwickele
sich nicht zu beobachtet wurde noch ein
präsent die türen
stattfindet steht den es wahrscheinlich
die vielfalt ausgesetzt ist das anderen
und so oder aber das natürlich vor dass
in ihrer stadt
wirklich geht und in boppelsen der
interlakner spielte kasache durch viel
mehr anreize
und nicht thomas städtler
wirtschaftsmotor und die kulturelle
motor und progressive tag findet findet
er das ganze
steht oder diskussionen zum beispiel
minister stroh und lang verdiene oder wc
für alle ist natürliches produkt jetzt
stellen statt und ist eigentlich aber
ich finde trotzdem bleibe die sogenannte
polyphonie für der stadt die
vielstimmigkeit das ist so dämlich
albachten russische philosoph
und was du mit anderen in kontakt wunsch
von der
großstadt anonym ich sehr viel in die
stimmlage und finger weg sind in
offendorf ist chance relativ reader sind
irgendwie spezielle fröhliche beherrscht
oder spezielle identität das duo zugibt
dass die stadt findet das erinnert ja
also ich repressiver
gebracht auf dem dorf paradox resort
stadträte aber es ist die anonymität
wegen ein stück freiheit zurückgibt und
hier gibt es gibt viele sonstige rx-7
der seit gewünscht aber
es geht so dass das exzentrische
das irgendwie dass sich ausprobieren und
er bis extremes machen uns fällt weniger
ruf dass beobachtung armee steht und das
ist nicht nur eben eine freiheits- und
zwar aus und druck bis sonntags müssen
sich speziell besser 7 ist der emas und
andere nicht von der seite das
interessant ist im aufsatz dass ich vor
übersäuerung der george peppard die
großstädte und das geistesleben vom
beliebte mentalität von der steckt drin
ist die glasiert haid dass so eine
seines absturzes in panzer oder der
musterkläger damit du die
reizüberflutung muss halt
new
york/los korte tauschten bemüht werden
kontrolliert aber für uns zudem die
reizüberflutung das ist ein bisschen
wenn man über die stadt blieben
natürlich andere philosophie zum teil
ganz großartig gründe an zum beispiel
der walter benjamin wo es im passage
wäre heute berliner chronik dass er
beschrieb die reize beschuldigt die
viele niedrig dass für in der stadt dass
das alles ganz fantastisch aus bisher
stehen in der berliner klinik gibt die
schöne idee aber dass er
sich für ihre innenstadt extrem
schwierig machen versuche zu finden ein
stadtplan ob ich für ihre dass ich finde
dass ich einfach schwierig das heißt das
stück wird sich selber moskau und st das
getöse ihnen stürzen und tretminen
archivlösung und deswegen die beschreibt
er so schön bedeutet das dass das das
unglaublich gewesen war bisher sicher
das einsteigen mit einer mobilen also
fragen gestellt eine bürgerreise und so
aber ich habe jetzt einige broker
schalten sich automatisch und für
private nicht geben wir bekannt
wurde machen so und commodities ganz
anders für mich ist natur viel
inspiration
und dass man drauf dortmund so
außenstadt aber ich dafür jetzt noch
unterscheidet testzeit inspiration sold
und sehnsuchtsort und ich würde sagen
mir gott das auf ganz ganz große
sehnsucht immer wieder nachts ganz
extrem aber was ist das genau für die
sehnsucht ich glaube sie schnitt 10 sich
nach einer schlappe wie sicher auf dem
dorf herum stand sehr viel
eigentlich ein
vergesellschaftet das hätte ich mir
jedes auto oder zweirad oder gar astoria
der das trampolin und swimmingpool und
es ist sehr kontrolliert ist überspitzt
aber so dass gas umgestellt das wird die
in finnland oder das neue phase der
bündner
genau dass sie eigentlich auf dem blauen
und wendig bonus im land das stimmt
sicher nicht für alle dass das ein
rückzug ist einsamkeit viel waren jungs
land und trotzdem gut abbauen und
einigen anderen durchgangsstraße einig
was aber wirklich klanglos ihr keine
extrem kurz aber ich möchte sie nicht
benennen aus ein ort wo inspiration wird
statt inspiration plausibel die
inspiration und dem land hessen und der
dort auf das duell abschloss sagt dass
du zu der wunsch dass du gut frei danke
aber die inspiration
und so findet wieder so versuche statt
freunde und land hier
und da ihre citycar zum schreiben und
zum selber finden und es gibt die ganze
tradition von jean jacques rousseau
und so die natur liechtenstein aber auch
heidekraut rallye die hütte geschrieben
gibt er finde es gibt mir aus oder
hinter schlummernd zwei vorstellungen
zwei ideal vor selbstentfaltung oder
selbst war die ganze ist das social
studies modul zu dir selber finde wenn
du möglichst frei bessere idee ist ganz
einfach seitlich einer summe von einer
pflanze das dass ich ein vater und
großvater und andere als gegenmodell
natürlich mit dem hegau könnt ihr also
zu jeder zeit leitet er in schwaben also
die muss ich zugeben muss die sachen
kultur eignen sich selber 200 muss mir
zu sagen ich glaube fremdworte und dandy
mit dem andere können wieder finden und
ich glaube das ist das ist schon
interessant
städtische lagern und tornister also
progressiv oder ich weiß nicht so recht
ob ein erhöhtes land zieht ob man
wirklich gesellschaft verroht will
zerstörung york tätig hat den zugang auf
das internet und genau wie der minister
ist resort gott wie sind eigentlich
mekka blöd oder wir können das wellness
resort mit laptop mit docetaxel anni
lage und das ganze wirklich aus der
gesellschaft aus dem trubel
gar nicht statt
ich denke ich musste daran trug geschäft
sei aber genau hier wirklich die flucht
vor dem soziale aber sofort von einer
konkurrenz von mini
ich glaube schon wenn historische stück
größer die soziale überwachung und dafür
gleich und so paradox ist besser jetzt
noch menschen hätte schiri zu seinem
rivalen was du was du machst im land
heißt ganz vieles geht von stadt land
graben und ob sie wirklich gibt und wir
bücher offen ist extrem umstritten und
diskutiert er vor allem auch politisch
für die hin und es geht natürlich partei
ganz klar sagen das gibt der stadt land
graben und steckt ihrer politik auf dem
land wo mir überhaupt nicht wenn und
wäre
maro zerstört
über jo sagen muss der finanzausgleich
und der schweiz kennen das kann sie die
strukturschwächeren regionen
gelten von der struktur stärkere die
profitiere massiv oder städters kapieren
aus prozent umgibt wird in der urbanen
zentren erwirtschaftete der schweiz wo
mit nahtloser das land ist nicht wichtig
wie das taxi erwidert schwächlichen vom
bruttoinlandprodukt von der musikwelt
also überschrieben und was oft tanken
vom land wasser
und das ist ja auch ganz wichtige
ressourcen wie zb sogenannte ständemehr
wo an gilt wie initiative zum beispiel
damals standen und ganz oft initiative
genau denn ich finde seine ideen sind
ungerecht wenn ich finde das schon der
versuch in der demokratie zwar generell
weniger lügt dass sie nicht einfach tun
und bestimmt werden stimmt genau also
habe schweiz macht vielleicht gut die
sache zum der stadt-land-graben nicht zu
großem schaden des projekts
großmeister mehrheit der eigentliche
bestattung wird die ganze 2
das
ist irre der verzehr der
stadt-land-graben die kids eine schöne
unterscheidung von politologe von david
guthardt wo seit gt2 mentalität
körperseite so zeigt die anywhere und
die samwer stanley works die endlichkeit
sind die urban kosmopolitische
städterinnen und städter akademiker so
oft war ich über rauchen von klappern
und und schaffen und sehr sehr offen was
dass er gott und die andere die sagen
gut verwurzelt sind dass bestimmte
universum
sowie als kind am stadtrand mit krise
und so
ich glaub samuel musste ich den auf
natur beziehe und nicht dafür dass
bestimmte store von ihren sitzen ich bin
nicht unbedingt zahlen zurück oder
liegen wie das quartier in der hofgasse
bin danach einstichstelle oder
ineinander stadt habe irgendwelche hatte
jörg macht klar was auf totschlag bleibt
ist eine krise wieder weg ich habe mir
das vorstelle das ist aber leider meine
jungs machen also dass
serbien aber die momentane
herausforderung mit familie job und das
mit sägen
[Musik]
ich glaube ich wäre in any way also ist
aber vielen orten wurzelstock was immer
wieder mehr kann ich schon mit der
schweiz verbindet mich viel heimat das
ist auf jeden fall so zum beispiel mit
dem dialog treten
das hauptziel wendige geht waren so
vertraut sind aber letztendlich ist
die mixtur hand sind mir ganz klar
menschen bettina und diesen hat mir mit
acht verstreut um den erdball das heißt
nur gezwungenermaßen zum anywhere stadt
oder land wo anders als gerne kommentare
sind gespannt wir haben mit dem
philosophen michael hampe geräte
beziehen sich nach der natur und mit dem
richard sennett dem großen soziologe
stadt in der man fleisch und passat
freuen wo ist denn aktivieren doch
locker bis bald